anyway confidence is key and then part
of that confidence david marcelo friends
out there in valuetainment land in
youtube land let me say hi david if you
see some people some of our friends you
can say hi to them while we're doing
this usual suspects john
part of i'm pulling this up
part of confidence are the words
that you use and
certain words
are more effective than others certain
words can go a long way while certain
words might hurt your cause right so
there's some experts you know when you
think of words there's experts like
linguists psychologists recruiters ceos
even that basically say these are the
words that you should use and these are
the words that you should stay away from
so let's get into this list what do you
think let's do it
so you ever have a conversation with
somebody and they say so here's what i'm
saying on page three uh you can see that
the uh tps report does that make sense
no does that make sense zero clear that
makes sense
so what they're saying
so what they're saying is
the the whole does that make sense
doesn't it's not a productive question
why is that
it's because
what they're saying is that you you
should ask for is what are your thoughts
because basically what you're looking
for is feedback when you say does that
make sense does that make sense they're
either going to say yes or if the answer
is no they're still going to say yes
because they don't want to sound stupid
does that make sense no
of course they're going to say yes for
the most part so
when you say yes
you're just kind of just moving the
conversation along so the difference
between saying does that make sense or
what are your thoughts is getting
feedback or just getting a yes or no
question marcelo does that make sense
yes
um
yeah what are your thoughts um well i
think the what did you see how he's
speaking now yeah yeah yeah yeah right
right
i'm going to say that what it really is
what it really works on doing is making
the people talk it's like if you say
does that make sense they don't have to
be paying attention or not exactly just
say yes and then you're moving on but if
you say what are your thoughts that's
also kind of being like were you paying
attention yes you know what i mean give
me some feedback david does that make
sense yeah absolutely how old what
how awkward yeah like what are your
thoughts
right well i wasn't even listening made
a great point anyway so words matter
little things like that so rather than
saying i i actually had a phone call
with a with a colleague or a business
guy and after every point he made he
said does that make sense and i just by
default said yes
does that make sense yes yeah absolutely
i wasn't paying attention
you know
five minutes in we spoke for a half hour
does that make sense it was almost like
it was something that was built into his
dna like he took a class and said does
that make sense and he was told to
repeat it so basically number one
replace does that make sense with what
are your thoughts and you'll get actual
feedback rather than a yes or no
response
i like it okay that makes sense thank
you we're looking to make sense two
cents all right number two
on this list
instead of saying
maybe we should try
or maybe we should go here how about
maybe we should just what you should say
is
let's try
no maybe no maybe it's basically the
difference between being confident let's
do this
or being wishy-washy maybe we should go
to the movies
maybe we should go to the mexican
restaurant
let's try the mexican restaurant for
dinner with confidence wow
how authoritative you're showing up and
and they can reject you they can say no
i don't want to try it but at least you
sound like you're sure of what you're
saying confidence this whole thing is
about confidence are you believing in
what you're saying let's try the new
sushi restaurant maybe we should try the
new sushi right now do you see how his
voice changed
do you see the voice
that's how you knew that i was being
more confident exactly the voice change
so
uh
may so stop basically the the the the
using the word of maybe
words matter again confidence matters
confidence is key
okay right so
maybe we should try
stop using we does that make sense or
stop using
does that make sense
see what i did there no none of that
made sense
so that's number two you either believe
in what you're talking about or you
don't and the maybe is sort of
disclaimer that you don't know what
you're talking about david okay
uh number three on this list to help
your confidence
lose
the butts
lose the butts
i'm not sure but i think we should go
to
the mall today or this might be a stupid
question
but what do you thought no
or i don't want to be too pushy
but can i have another soda relax
so what they're saying to say instead is
whatever you were going to say
after the butt
okay
basically they're saying don't add
disclaimers to undermine yourself so i
don't want to be too pushy but
can i get another refill on my soda
rather than doing that is just be please
can i have another refill in my soda
okay and when you when it applies to
business i don't want to be pushy
but
uh you were gonna get back to me with
feedback
on the new design uh layout of the the
plan all right
hey you were gonna get back to me with
the design layout what's the status
they're basically saying the whole
concept here is just like get to the
point get to where's the stop using
disclaimers there it is
stop undermining yourself
okay
there's that any thoughts on that oh
what are your thoughts i have thoughts i
agree i think uh disclaimers hurt you no
matter what there's it can't help you to
put a disclaimer i might be an idiot but
it's like dude just say what you're
gonna say
disclaimers don't help unless it's
medicine then you should include
disclaimers for legal purposes yes take
this x y and z yes but if you're
pregnant
if you're caring child you might not
want to do that okay number four
we just talked about lose the butts
lose
the just now this is something that i do
in emails all the time
hey rick just touching base i do that
all the time hey sally
just wanted to see how you're doing
hey bill
just want to find out what's just shut
with the just yeah that's what they're
basically saying they just say just say
touching base
finding out
again this is we talked about not using
a disclaimer unless someone's pregnant
or whatever you know
uh or
checking the medicine whatever that was
the just is just softening your message
it's sort of like you look weak yeah you
look weak again that's all i'm doing
what was that right there
just just just look at this just
just look at the
just just checking in just checking in
you don't need that that's all yeah just
shut up
just say what you were going to say say
it so it's it's almost like you're
apologizing right it's like saying i
hate i hate to bother you just wanted to
also i'm bothering you sir what's the
status of the tps report right
also like with uh i feel like if you're
asking somebody out or anything like
that you know i was just wondering if
yes it's like
i was just wondering what you're doing
uh saturday night what are you doing
saturday night
[Laughter]
dude it's honestly true though yeah i
think like in general like no matter
what business you're in like even if
you're
like flipping burgers somewhere if you
were like need help you're like hey i
just wanted to see if you could help me
over here at my station let me get a
little help over here buddy exactly i
would send you like i'd be like oh this
person is weak i don't have to listen to
them
well so anyway we talked about not
adding disclaimers we talked about not
adding words that soften your message
again not confidence you know what
possibly is the least
confident word that you can constantly
use for no reason is the word
sorry stop apologizing if you haven't
done anything wrong
if you messed up you screwed up you did
something stupid apologize man up and do
it quickly and do it
on point i'm so sorry like this is for
sure but if you didn't do anything wrong
why are you apologizing hey i'm sorry to
bother you yeah but i just wanted you to
know that at my car you know you're not
bothering me at all just tell me this is
what happened hey i'm so sorry but would
you mind moving like to just hey would
you mind moving a couple feet away
that's not a big deal so
what they're saying to use instead is
excuse me
because you're you're butting in on what
they're saying excuse me so
psychologists basically say that the
people that use the word or overuse the
word i'm sorry
lack
confidence
again confidence is key
confidence is key
why do you think you see like really
let's just call a spade a spade here not
such attractive in the face guys
damn with pretty women
confidence and money and money and money
and maybe that's true but with money
comes confidence or the money but yeah
but most of the money and maybe that's
true for jobs too you see guys that are
not that smart but they got a great job
or they're high up in the company and
you're like damn that guy's not that
quick on his feet
but he's got confidence yes you know
what i mean marcelo yes you have
confidence perhaps i i'm definitely it's
definitely gotten me out of a few tight
binds if like i'm saying a joke that
sucks or that doesn't really work but
then i just spit it out with some
confidence yep might have saved my ass
once or twice david yeah you have
confidence yeah i bet you were dating a
girl at one point who said i'm not that
into
uh you know good-looking guys
[Laughter]
i mean i i also don't know where this is
going i don't know where you're going
with yourself
i'm just saying you have confidence yeah
you're calling him ugly i'm not saying
that the girl that he was dating did
but she liked his confidence right well
i'm not saying in addition to his
mustache
but the point is this
confidence is key ladies if you're ugly
if you're dumb if you're not talented
confident i'm telling you just look at
david
look at his stupid face look at adam
look at that mustache i'm confident
confident no clue what i'm talking about
i'm going to sell you everything this is
what you need to do confidence but
confidence is key and listen last but
not least we talked about
um
using what are your thoughts rather than
does that uh does that make sense
because you can get better feedback we
talked about being direct
with let's try rather than maybe let's
try we talked about losing the butts but
this we talked about losing the just
just wanted to we talked about stop
saying sorry but let's give a little
bonus right here because when i hear
people say this
it drives me mad know what i'm saying
so you know i went to the park the other
day you know what i'm saying so then you
know the note i'm saying the you know
what i mean
no which is does that make sense this
which
which is just it's the yeah they're
basically saying you know what you
should say instead of you know what i'm
saying nothing right stop saying that
[ __ ] right yeah i saw a guy say that
yeah he was uh he plays sports
he was giving a uh press conference
and you know
uh the raiders they did a good job you
know what i'm saying and uh but our team
we tried real hard you know what i'm
saying and uh eventually you know we
didn't win the game you know what i'm
saying but
no buddy i i i know what you're saying
just say it right but that's also a
business where you don't really got to
speak that well to succeed but if you're
a regular if you're in sales if you're
in work even if you're a comedian i got
to stop saying you know what i mean i
say it a lot so as a comedian 100 i say
it a lot and i shouldn't i should just
be silent so i think you know in sports
it's different but like if you're a
salesman or a manager or like you know
somebody that has to lead it can't be
you know what i'm meaning you know what
i mean and because basically it's a
filler phrase that means nothing nothing
it means nothing and it actually
irritates people no i'm saying
yeah it's like you think they're dumb
you're like are you keeping up with this
it's just i think it's one of those
words that has
made it into the culture that nobody
said just stop this right now and just
you know what other word i and
a friend of mine's father pointed this
out to me
and it i was like
right there i just did it like the word
like right right right i was like what
i i actually
there was a girl i'm kind of friends
with talking to whatever
and in person
i you know we're we're
we go out we hang out and i didn't
notice it but i called her on the phone
and i realized she said like
every three seconds
and i didn't notice it in person but on
the phone because there's no
extra curricular stuff going on right
i'm just listening
and it's driving me mad how much she
said
it's like i went to the you know to the
bar and like the guy said like and i
don't i was just chill out with all that
know what i'm saying say less say
lessons the lesson here say less say
less work on how you speak anyway
exactly work on how you speak exactly
thank you marcelo no matter what
business you're in whether you're a
comedian whether you're a producer
whether you're the guy on the podium
speaking
you know sports or not
words do matter it's a huge part of
business so let me tell you something
it's not about and it doesn't matter
about
brain smart resume it's not about how
much you know it's about how you can
convey what you know
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke